cependant une grande guerre se prépare
la serbie et la bulgarie se disputent la
macédoine par les armes se forme alors
deux grandes coalitions
la serbie a lié à la russie à la
roumanie à la grèce au portugal au
royaume uni à la france et à l'italie
contre la bulgarie allié à l'autriche à
l'allemagne et à l' empire ottoman dans
l'héritier du trône austro hongrois est
assassiné par des serbes
c'est l'étincelle qui provoque la
première guerre mondiale l'allemagne
envahit la belgique et le luxembourg
arrivant près de paris mais soudain tout
change
l'autriche sort de la guerre une défaite
militaire et une révolution ayant aboli
la monarchie
la première république autrichienne et
proclamé une révolution éclate aussi en
allemagne
l'empereur est obligé d'abdiquer et la
première république allemande coupé en
deux entités territoriales est proclamé
c'est la fin de la guerre la turquie 10
ou l'environnement et passe au statut de
république démocratique
l'ukraine et la biélorussie prennent
leur indépendance vis-à-vis de la russie
la serbie annexe la slovénie la croatie
la macédoine la bosnie herzégovine et le
monténégro formant le royaume de
yougoslavie en russie aussi une
révolution éclate le tsar est éliminé et
l'union des républiques socialistes
soviétiques est proclamé cela permet à
la pologne de renaître
tout comme la finlande l'estonie la
lettonie et la lituanie
la hongrie se détache de l'autriche et
prend son indépendance
les slovaques et les tchèques s'unissent
pour constituer la république de
tchécoslovaquie la roumanie reprend la
moldavie et l'union soviétique reprend
l'ukraine et la biélorussie
l'irlande prend son indépendance et se
renomme hey hey mais elle est dérivée
des comtés du nord qui choisissent de
rester dans le royaume uni
en europe cependant les dangers ne sont
pas tous écartés des dictateurs prennent
le pouvoir
au portugal les militaires suspens des
libertés en italie le roi confie le
gouvernement à mussolini qui établit la
dictature fasciste toutefois mussolini
permet la création de l'état de la cité
du vatican
enclavée dans la ville de rome comme
siège des institutions de l'église
catholique romaine en estonie en
lituanie et en lettonie les militaires
instaure la dictature
en espagne c'est le général franco qui
prend le pouvoir en allemagne
hitler est nommé chancelier et se
proclame fureur
adolf hitler chef d'un parti politique à
l'idéologie nationaliste et raciste
prônant le nazisme ambitionne l'arrêt
constitution de l' empire allemand
d'avant guerre il rattache alors
l'autriche à l'allemagne reprendre les
anciens territoires allemands en
tchécoslovaquie et attaque la pologne la
partageant avec l'union soviétique cela
provoque la réaction de la france et du
royaume uni
allié à la pologne la seconde guerre
mondiale éclate le royaume uni attaque
l'allemagne mais hitler contre attaque
il envahit le danemark la norvège les
pays-bas
la belgique le luxembourg et la france
parvenant même à bombarder le royaume
uni par avion enfin concluant avec le
japon et l'italie
le pacte de lax hitler occupe la
slovaquie et le royaume de hongrie
tandis que l'italie occupe l'albanie et
le royaume de graisse fortement
préoccupé le premier ministre du royaume
uni winston churchill et le général
français charles de gaulle en exil à
londres font alors appel aux nations du
monde pour former une coalition anti
nazi ap les armées alliées
pour sa part l'union soviétique de
joseph staline ambitionne la domination
de l'europe orientale devenu un état de
régime communiste elle attaque la
finlande l'estonie la lettonie la
lituanie et la roumanie
mais la finlande et la roumanie se
rebelle suivi par la bulgarie et s'allie
à hitler envahit alors le royaume de
yougoslavie et se dirige vers moscou
l'union soviétique à l'armée rejoint le
camp des armées alliées
tout comme les etats-unis et la chine en
guerre contre un membre de l' axe le
japon
le conflit devient mondiale
hitler attaque l'immense union
soviétique
mais les dures conditions climatiques de
ce pays ils écouteront un quart de ses
coûts et qu'au second sa défaite
il est en effet battu par les armes et
communistes qui avance jusqu'à la mer
adriatique établissant leur régime sur
les pays assujettis pour les nazis c'est
la déroute les armées alliées des
etats-unis du canada du royaume uni
attac l'italie et renversent les
fascistes puis elle débarque en france
et aigle général de gaulle à chasser les
troupes allemandes hitler se suicident
l'allemagne capitule
les pays occupés par les nazis sont
libérés c'est la paix étant les états
unis lancent la bombe atomique sur le
japon
les conflits cesse définitive pour
assurer le maintien de la paix
l'organisation des nations unies est
alors créée sa finalité est le
remplacement des conflits par le
dialogue
mais le cas échéant l'onu peut employer
des casques bleus sa force armée pour
rétablir la paix 51 pays signent la
charte des nations unies dont les
membres permanents sont les états-unis
l'union soviétique la chine la france et
le royaume uni
bien qu ayant consenti à rendre son
indépendance à la finlande
l'union soviétique absorbe la tchéquie
et reconstitue la tchécoslovaquie dans
les balkans le maréchal tito fondent la
république fédérale socialiste de
yougoslavie de régime communiste mais
détaché de la tutelle de moscou tout
comme l'albanie qui embrasse le
communisme mais conserve son
indépendance
en allemagne le nazisme est déclaré
illégal et le pays est à nouveau divisé
en deux d'un côté la république fédérale
d'allemagne contrôlé par les armées
alliées et de l'autre la république
démocratique d'allemagne contrôlé par
les soviets
l'europe aussi est divisée la conférence
de yalta entre les deux puissances
victorieuses les états unis et l'union
soviétique partage l'europe en deux
blocs
dans le bloc occidental sous influence
américaine certains pays si l'accord de
l'otan pour se protéger contre
d'éventuelles agressions soviétique dans
le bloc oriental sous influence
soviétique
certains pays signent le pacte de
varsovie pour se protéger des américains
toutefois l'armée soviétique réprime
durement des mouvements indépendantistes
en hongrie sans que les nations
occidentales puisse intervenir
c'est la guerre froide entre les deux
blocs qui ne peuvent plus entrer en
guerre directement à cause de la
dissuasion nucléaire acquises par les
états unis l'union soviétique la
république populaire de chine le
royaume-uni et la france
l'europe cependant on a assez des
conflits ces nations sont jeta un modèle
d'intégration qu'ils n'émettraient à
jamais à l'abri d'une nouvelle guerre le
ministre français sumann alors l'idée de
mettre les industries européennes liées
aux armements sous le contrôle
réciproque des deux principaux
producteurs de fer et de charbon
la france et l'allemagne il s'ensuit le
traité de rome où la communauté
économique européenne est créé
son but est un rapprochement économique
qui permet la libre circulation des
personnes des marchandises des services
et des capitaux entre les pays membres
les signataires sont la france l'italie
l'allemagne de l'ouest
la belgique le luxembourg et les pays
bas
chypre prend enfin son indépendance
vis-à-vis du royaume-uni et passe au
statut de république
malte aussi proclame l'indépendance et
la république mais reste dans le
commonwealth une organisation composée
du royaume uni et de ses colonies dans
le bloc oriental l'armée soviétique
intervient encore étouffant les
rébellion indépendantiste en tchéquie
dans le bloc occidental
la communauté économique européenne
s'élargit avec l'adhésion du danemark de
l'irlande et du royaume uni
a chip les chypriotes grecs et les
chypriotes d'ethnie turc s'affrontent
durement la turquie occupe alors
militairement le nord de l'île le nomme
en république turque de chypre mais
cette république n'est pas reconnue par
la communauté internationale à
l'exception de la turquie
au portugal une révolution met fin à la
dictature militaire et la république est
rétabli malte sort enfin du commonwealth
et proclame sa totale indépendance
en grèce après la dictature des colonels
la république est proclamée dans
l'espagne où blé par des luttes
d'indépendance menée par les basques le
général franco rétabli la monarchie sous
régime constitutionnel
actuellement tous les royaumes et les
principautés d'europe ont embrassé la
monarchie constitutionnelle avec un
premier ministre comme chef du
gouvernement
la communauté économique européenne
s'élargit encore avec l'adhésion de la
grèce de l'espagne et du portugal
un grand changement s'opère en union
soviétique
la pérestroïka de michel gratchev met
fin au bloc communiste et la république
fédérale de russie est proclamé cela
permet à l'allemagne d'abattre le mur de
berlin et de se réunifier en un seul
pays à la tchécoslovaquie leur devenir
deux pays distincts la république
tchèque et la république de slovaquie et
à la pologne la bulgarie l'estonie
la lettonie
la lituanie la hongrie la roumanie la
moldavie l'ukraine et la biélorussie de
devenir des républiques indépendantes
l'indépendance s'est déclaré aussi en
slovénie en croatie en macédoine et en
bosnie-herzégovine par rapport à la
république fédérale de yougoslavie qui
est désormais réduit à la seule union
serbie monténégro
le régime communiste est abandonnée même
en albanie qui passe au statut de
république démocratique
avec l'adhésion de l'autriche de la
finlande et de la suède
la communauté économique européenne
devient l'union européenne et met en
circulation sa devise l'euro une monnaie
commune aux états membres de la zone
euro
cela attire l'estonie la lettonie la
lituanie la pologne la tchéquie la
slovaquie
la hongrie la slovénie malte et chypre
qui rejoigne l'union européenne
dans les balkans la serbie et le
monténégro se séparent le venant de
république indépendance
l'union européenne devient l'europe des
après l'adhésion de la roumanie et de la
bulgarie en serbie
la province du kosovo proclame la
république mais elle n'est pas reconnu
par la majorité des pays membres de
l'organisation des nations unies à ce
jour la croatie a d'ores et déjà rejoint
l'union européenne le monténégro
l'albanie la macédoine l'islande et la
turquie demande l'adhésion à l'union
européenne dont la zone euro s'est
élargi à 16 nations mais la requête de
la turquie est conditionné par les
troubles entre les deux communautés de
chypre
la grande histoire de l'europe vous a
été compté
sur ce continent magnifique s'est peu à
peu bâti la civilisation occidentale qui
inspire maintenant par ses valeurs
le monde entier sur cette terre
millénaire les nations parmi les plus
puissantes du monde se sont constitués
bouleversant souvent le destin des
peuples
aujourd'hui après trois mille ans de
conflit l'europe
animé par l'idée audacieuse une
structure supranationale inédite dans
l'histoire de l'humanité est parvenu à
unir pacifiquement dans l'union
européenne et pays de langues et de
cultures différentes
cela lui a valu le prix nobel de la paix
en 2012
la suprématie économique mondiale et
surtout une période de paix la plus
longue depuis les temps anciens de l'
empire romain
il est bien loin l'instant où la
princesse europe se baignant près d'une
plage croiser à son regard avec celui 2
le roi des dieux